In general, humans primarily function off
of self-interest.
This sounds like a sad thought to bear that
even in the purist appearing of people, self-interest
can still remain.
But perhaps it’s not entirely a bad thing.
Perhaps we can use selfishness to achieve
selfLESSness.
On commercial airplanes, in the case of an
oxygen shortage, adults are instructed to
put oxygen masks on themselves before they
assist children or other incapable passengers.
Arguably, this could be considered selfish,
but its purpose is selfLESS.
It is logical.
An individual cannot help anyone breathe if
they are unable to breathe themselves.
Likewise, one cannot give something to the
world if they do not have it themselves.
An unhappy person cannot help the world be
happy and a person without love cannot give
the world love.
In life, a person must first work to satisfy
their own needs, even if they may initially
appear selfish.
Needs like survival, self-love, self-awareness,
self-fulfillment, and so on.
If our selfish acts are calculated and purposeful
towards providing us with the capacity to
carry out the needs of others, we move through
selfishness and into selflessness.
The problem with this process is how easy
it is to become swept away by our self-interest
and forget about the purpose of using it to
achieve selflessness.
We are seductive to ourselves and easily become
addicted to creating a world around our ego.
We must resist, though, and maintain a balance
between our self and the rest of the world.
Well-being is rooted in altruism.
It cannot merely be self-oriented.
Just like a financial investor invests portions
of their money into a business, you must invest
portions of yourself into others and trust
that your quality of life will accrue in value.
And when it does, you will ironically end
up with what your selfishness wanted the whole
time; a better life.
But at least in this case, you will have positively
affected others along the way and will have
shared in a collective happiness that is enduring
and wondrous.